the video is off me
having my weekly two-hour contact with
Beth it's talking to her holding her
hand through a hatch in it in a cell
door that I could hold a hand I could
stroke her face I could kiss it goodbye
on a cheek and I could talk to have to
kneel down and talk to you a child like
that not because she's a criminal but
because she's autistic and I'm supported
is is uh something horrific it's it's
degrading now I don't even have that
now there is no hatch
bethenny has autism at 15 she was
sectioned under the Mental Health Act
after she was deemed a risk to herself
and others but the care didn't prepare
Bethenny for community-based support and
when she was released she simply
couldn't cope Bethenny and Jeremy would
like Beth's face shown in these photos
but neither has the right as she's under
state care so people send things and I
get everything from from lovely cards
with jokes in Jeremy was forced to take
NHS England st. Andrews health care and
his local authority too cause they have
now all accepted that they failed in
their duty of care and have made changes
to improve the care of people with
autism
despite this Beth has now been moved to
a unit that's even more restrictive than
the one where she was held before this
is not because of what Bethany is done
but because of what they feel she might
do
Beth is locked away it is a cell there's
no furniture in that room there is a
four inch thick mattress on the floor
that she sleeps on there's there's not a
window that she can see out of when it
comes to feeding Beth Beth has to move
to the end of the room sit on the floor
behind a line only then will they open
the door slide her food in and then
quickly lock the door again
it's just 21st century Britain
absolutely that's like feeding a vicious
dog my daughter is not an animal how you
that you've seen for me lately showmen
that's that's brilliant
Jeremy is only allowed to see his
daughter for a couple of hours once a
week but he can speak to her on the
phone every day
twin baby sure you want something that
smells like a real baby it'll give you
some company Oh Beth
the unit where Beth is being held
accepts it's unsuited to her needs and
she needs to be moved a report into the
failure of Bethany's care now sits on
the health Secretary's desk it makes
more than 80 recommendations we are just
being placated with review after review
after review that needs to stop my
Hancock needs to make the changes that
his report says are needed Beth is being
failed because of a lack of availability
of community placements she is being
failed because of a lack of people with
the right training with the right skills
we asked Matt Hancock for an interview
but was told he was not available his
Department confirmed that they have
received the review and we're looking at
it closely NHS England his told Sky News
it's working with Bethany and her family
to agree and manage an ongoing plan for
her care almost the last time you were
able to put your arms around your
daughter weeks ago how did that feel if
I had known it was gonna be the last
time I wouldn't think I go she begs to
have her hand held like she used to be
able to do in st. Andrews you can't
there wasn't a hatch now Jeremy has
bought Bethany the dolls she wants they
might bring her some comfort but they
can never replace the warm embrace of a
loving father
Ashish Joshi Sky News